morning all 10 000 nurses in England
Wales and Northern Ireland are on strike
in a dispute over pay and conditions it
is the second walkout in less than a
week and ambulance staff are due to
follow them tomorrow the health
secretary is meeting unions this morning
but the government says it won't talk
about pay so guys I've abandoned reports
[Music]
no strikes for over a hundred years and
now two within a week the party
atmosphere of the picket lines
concealing anger and exhaustion
[Music]
foreign ER Sean Williams will be
striking at birmingham's Queen Elizabeth
Hospital where the fundamental issue for
him is patient care
it's not a pleasant environment to be
you train as a nurse and you practice as
a nurse wanting to give the best care
and treatment you can and when you can't
do that it's it's self-destroying so
patients are already suffering the oh
yes yeah and what extent to what extent
this care is not getting done and cares
and cares being missed and now even more
care will be missed or at least
postponed last week's walkout resulted
in 16 000 appointments being canceled
anyone who comes to Hospital for an
emergency will still be seen with all
Critical Care units remaining
operational but the strike means there
will be thousands of patients up and
down the country who will have
appointments and surgeries canceled and
the disruption is unlikely to end here
that's because negotiations with the
government are deadlocked overpay and
the nurses Union is now threatening to
repeat these scenes next year for up to
six months
if that's what we need to do then that's
what we will continue but we really do
not want to have to escalate the size of
the strikes the numbers
um that of members that we take are on
strike at any one time but all of these
are things that we'll need to consider
if the government doesn't take it
seriously and it seems the government's
now under pressure from elsewhere too
the damage that you're doing to families
like myself is terrible the health
secretary Steve Barkley was publicly
rebuked on a hospital visit yesterday by
this mother of a three-year-old patient
who'd had her treatment delayed we have
some brilliant expert and they'll be in
work to the bones
you know and actually the level of care
they provide is amazing but they're not
being able to provide it in the way they
want to provide it because the
resourcing's not there
but when it comes to nurses pay that's
exactly what the government says that
the resources aren't there so for now
it's a Face-Off in which neither sign is
blinking either Bennett Sky News
Birmingham
uh well there will be picket lines at
hospitals across the country today one
of those will be at St Thomas's Hospital
in central London our correspondent
children will be there throughout the
morning that sadly I suspect not much
action there just know but going by the
last time the Striking was there will be
lots and lots of nurses behind you
yes it's fairly quiet now and look it is
the run-up to Christmas but actually
nursing is one of those professions
isn't it that it doesn't really matter
what date of the year it is it is likely
to have an impact when nurses walk out
and that is set to happen today as 10
000 nurses across England Wells and
Northern Ireland will walk out the NHS
is due to run a bank holiday style
service today that means that uh some
procedures and operations will get
canceled or rescheduled but uh Critical
Care units you know dialysis things like
chemotherapy
Pediatric Intensive Care those
departments are still set to be staffed
by nursing but it will have inevitably
an impact on the public but the Royal
College of Nursing says that it has the
public on its side as it launches this
second day of action of course the last
one was last Thursday on the 15th of
December there is set to be a picket
line here from about 7 30 onwards it is
still fairly quiet here this morning but
we expect to meet lots of people as you
say as last time we saw how many people
turned up for that picket line and it's
then a chance for us to hear from nurses
about what they really want and I
suspect they'll tell us that it's all
about pay because they want the pay
increase the government's saying that
it's simply unaffordable at this time
but the Royal College of Nursing has
given the government up to 48 hours
after today's strike action ends to come
up with a response otherwise it says it
has the mandate to continue these
strikes into 2023 and for another six
months
thank you
all right well let's just remind you of
all the strikes that are taking place
over the coming days and there's more
than a couple of them as we've been
hearing members of the Royal College of
Nursing England Wales and Northern
Ireland they will be walking out for a
second time today ambulance staff
including paramedics Emergency Care
assistants call handlers they will be
striking on the 21st and the 28th
postal workers will stage another
two-day strike from the 23rd of December
borderful staff they'll be walking off
the job from the 23rd to the 26th and
then again from the 28th to the 31st
there will also be four more days of
real walkouts around Christmas uh
joining us now our political
correspondent Tamara good to see you
again this morning TC this one could run
and run couldn't it you look at the
rhetoric that we're hearing from from
Rishi sunak you look at the rhetoric and
the Mandate that the Royal College of
nurses have and this could last well
into the new year
certainly the nurses are already
threatening for it that it will last
well into the new year if there is no
resolution and it was pretty clear last
night that there wasn't going to be one
I think Minister's concerns are now
turning to the ambulance strike tomorrow
with both the paramedics and 999 call
handlers striking for the first time in
30 years and a number of ambulance
trusts in England and Wales and exactly
which calls they will be responding to
today Steve Barkley the health secretary
has called in representatives from the
three unions representing those
ambulance Workers Unite Unison and GMB
to a meeting around lunchtime to discuss
exactly what are these life and limb
emergencies because we know that
ambulances will be still responding to
category one call so immediate threat to
life but Category 2 calls which can
include heart attacks Strokes major
Burns may not get a response or a very
quick response so he ministers are very
concerned about what that might mean and
want to discuss it with the unions today
although they're supposed to be
hammering it out with each individual
trust as for how long this all might
last well Rishi sunak's given an
interview to the daily mail today saying
that he is willing to fight on against
the strikers he doesn't want to give in
on public sector pay which he says fuels
inflation but he also uses that
interview to set out his political
Vision sunachism if you like and the NHS
is crucial to it I'll read you a bit of
what he says in that interview he says
the first thing I want to deliver for
people is peace of mind peace of mind is
about knowing that public services like
the NHS are going to be there for you
and your family when you need them which
is why we are focusing on getting
waiting lists down of course getting
waiting lists down made a lot more
difficult by the threat of strikes
especially if they go on for a very long
time
indeed tomato thank you
of course the strikes dominating this
morning's front pages we begin with the
express which carries a call from the
nurses Union for the prime minister to
get personally involved in pain
negotiations
but in an interview with the mail Rishi
sunai describes the Royal College of
nursing's pay demands as unreasonable
the resulting disruption from both
strikes and the pleas to call them off
that is the main focus for the telegraph
sorry the Metro I should say chooses to
lead with the mother of a seriously ill
three-year-old who confronted the health
secretary in a hospital yesterday
here's the Ft it's reporting that the
health secretary Steve Barclay will meet
ambulance unions to discuss how they'll
handle emergency cover when they walk
out tomorrow
the guardian is carrying a warning from
NHS leaders that the ambulance strike
threatens the lives of 999 patients
the times reports that heart attack
patients won't necessarily be sent
ambulances
the eye says the same is true of stroke
victims
according to the sun would be ambulance
users are being advised to take taxis
instead
and we will be speaking to the health
Minister will Quince add around about 20
past and the little of unite the union
Shannon Graham just after eight o'clock
stay tuned for both of those but we turn
to the United States where a
congressional committee has unanimously
called for criminal charges to be
brought against Donald Trump over his
rule in the capital riots his support of
storm Congress on January the 6th 2021
to try and stop Joe Biden from being
certified as president a U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports
those in favor say aye aye
with one voice they shared a damning
conclusion
[Applause]
this Congressional committee had brought
us Insurrection and Inside Story
in the end it pointed the finger at its
principal actor I don't want to say the
election's over I just want to say
Congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
Donald Trump they said should be charged
with at least four offenses including
inciting or assisting an insurrection
the president has an affirmative and
primary constitutional duty to act to
take care that the laws be Faithfully
executed nothing could be a greater
betrayal of this Duty than to assist in
Insurrection against the Constitutional
order
committee hearings had used evidence
previously unseen and unheard to paint a
picture of the violence and Chaos that
was January the 6th
and there was testimony from the team
around Trump they spoke of his claims of
a rigged election I made it clear I did
not agree with the idea of saying the
election was stolen and putting out this
stuff which I told the president was
both
there was on the day encouragement to
the mall we fight like hell and
and fight like hell you're not going to
have a country anymore
[Music]
empathy is right was chanted hang Mike
Pence as the vice president tried to
certify the election for Joe Biden Mark
had responded something to the effect of
you heard of Pat he thinks Mike deserves
it he doesn't think they're doing
anything wrong
this committee has put Donald Trump
firmly in the frame if not in the dock
it's not for them to press charges
they're politicians that's beyond their
power but the recommendations have gone
to this country's Department of Justice
he is unfit for any office Trump's
initial response was for the committee
Vice chairless Jenny a reminder of her
40-point defeat in a Republican primary
election
it's all politics for now James Matthews
Sky News Washington
the disgraced Hollywood film producer
Harvey Weinstein has been found guilty
of rape in the trial in Los Angeles that
the 70 year old is already two years
into a 23-year sentence for a different
conviction in New York was those
allegations against him that ignited the
metoo movement the skiesner Qureshi
reports
Beyond the Palm trees in the luxury of
this five-star hotel and others across
Los Angeles Harvey Weinstein ruined
lives
any common Harvey the former film
producer was found guilty of rape second
conviction after he was sent to jail in
New York two years ago four women all
known as Jane doad to protect their
anonymity took the stand with similar
stories each though uniquely devastating
the first a model and actor was bent
over a sink and raped I wanted to die
she said I remember how he was looking
in the mirror and he was telling me to
look at him I've never seen a big guy
like that naked testifier Jane Doe too I
was really frail and he was a really big
man
Survivor Rowena Chu was a former
assistant to Weinstein she says he
assaulted her at the Venice Film
Festival it's a pretty terrifying
experience uh you know being a
a rabbit in a cage with a tiger wouldn't
go amiss I suppose I feel like you have
very little power obviously it's five
years now since the first allegations
against Weinstein were made public
breaking a generation's long culture of
silence and beginning the me too era
it's a movement which has spread to
workplaces around the world
although the jury couldn't reach a
unanimous guilty verdict on all claims
these dark secrets now brought into the
light will ensure Harvey Weinstein is
never released from prison the Croatia
Sky News
but let's return to our top story the
second walkout by thousands of nurses in
less than a week over pain conditions
let's speak to the health Minister will
Quince joins us from Westminster uh very
good morning to you Mr Quince um of
course it's not just the nurses striking
we have a pending ambulance strike as
well which does rather beg the question
taken together is there a risk to life
if these strikes go ahead could people
die as a result
well good good morning we are putting uh
all
um necessary derogations working with
the unions and individual trusts to make
sure that there are minimum service
levels both at ambulance trust level and
indeed a hospital trust level to ensure
patient safety is my number one priority
I know it's the number one priority of
NHS staff I hope it is also the number
one priority of the unions those
conversations are ongoing with ambulance
trusts and unions and only the Secretary
State and I have meetings with unions
later today to firm that up sure but if
they're going to be practically two
calls if they're not attending category
two calls which which is the implication
in parts of the country that that
minimum service level may not be
sufficient so I will ask the question
again well let me yeah let me be
absolutely clear on that our expectation
is that category 1 and Category 2 calls
are covered they are considered to be
life-threatening or emergency calls and
my call to the Union as I will repeat
later today is that category 1 and
Category 2 calls which make up around 50
percent of all calls to the ambulance
service should be covered as part of
derogations
the the complaint from the part of
specifically the paramedics and is that
you know people are currently dying as a
result of a service that is
overstretched I mean unite the union
admittedly not not your favorite people
in the world but through a freedom of
information request they discovered that
the West Midlands ambulance trust has
seen an absolutely staggering increase
in patient deaths nothing to do with the
trust in 2020 according to official
figures one patient died in the year
until September that in this year till
September 37 people have died because of
ambulance delays I mean the ambulance
the paramedics have a point don't they
so at the moment the the services below
where we would hope and expect it to be
in part that's pandemic driven it's
largely not down to the ambulance trust
itself but issues actually with bad
occupancy and discharge within hospitals
that's why we've put an extra half a
billion pounds into discharge this
winter opening up an extra 7 000 beds uh
but but on these issues my door and the
door of the secretary of state is is
open we want to discuss these with the
unions I'm having further conversations
with them later today but these are not
issues relating to pay which is the main
issue that is driving the conversations
uh on behalf of the the unions now
anything with regards to patients would
be tens of thousands with tens of
thousands of places you know of course
unoccupied unfilled within the Health
Service I gently suggest that perhaps P
does have something to do with it well
you specifically asked about paramedics
paramedics we have an extra three
thousand last year another three
thousand being recruited this year we
have 40 percent more paramedics and
ambulance staff compared to 2010 the the
issue is actually within Hospital trusts
and we are putting the resource in to
address that to ensure that the Handover
times within hospitals uh come down so
ambulances can get back out on the road
that is not that is not an issue
specific when it comes to ambulance
trusts uh and pay but the the critical
incident declared by the ambulance trust
in the Northeast because you know isn't
it because of the understaffing levels
that that presumably it doesn't fall
under what you were just describing
there so the largest the largest issue
is is around Handover delays and that
that is largely about bed occupancy
levels within hospitals flow within
hospitals and discharge into adult
social care they are all issues that we
are tackling but we're also building up
resilience within the ambulance trust to
an extra 150 million pounds an extra 20
million pounds uh invested in the fleet
and as I say we are investing in more
paramedics too and my door and the door
of the secretary of state is open when
it comes to discussing those issues
around patient safety and working
conditions for staff what we are not
willing to negotiate is reopening the
the pay for this year which is part of
the independent pay review body
recommendations which the government
accepted in full you say that your door
is open you say that that of Steve
Buckley's it is open as well
particularly as regards to the nurses
but is it is it potentially possible
that Rishi sunak closed that door and
put his foot up against it when he
stopped your boss from giving nurses a
one-off payment that could have brought
an end to these strikes
no I don't think that is the case so
where your right is that the NHS has a a
fixed fixed budget that is that was uh
set at the uh Autumn statement we had an
extra 3.3 billion pounds a year and
we've got important issues to tackle
including the covid backlog of around 7
million under patients
are not block a one-off payment no I I
haven't I haven't seen
um any any specific detail around uh
what one of one-off payments but what I
would say is this our door is the door
is open to discuss um with with the uh
with the unions anything relating to
working conditions what we what we can't
do now let's get is go back into
reopening the uh pay uh award which was
set by the recommendation by the
independent pay review uh body whose
recommendations we accepted uh in full
that they will now be looking to next
year as independent pay review body
recommendations to kick in from April
and let's not forget we're three
quarters of the way through this year
already and any extra extra percent over
the 1400 pounds or average four point
seven two percent a trace to 700 million
pounds
we are also you know Midway through a
kind of a period of extended strikes and
you know perhaps people might want to
get things sorted out I have to raise
something though Richie soon out this
morning giving a rather interesting
interview to the mail in which he kind
of talks about sunachism his kind of
political philosophy and he says this
which I think you know will cause people
to stop and stop and steer the first
thing Mr simack says that I want to
deliver for people is peace of mind
peace of mind is also about knowing that
public services like the NHS are going
to be there for you and your family when
you need them and then goes on to talk
about waiting list I mean is Mr like
taking the Mickey
no not not at all and if you if you look
at the most recent Autumn statement it
was exactly that public services that
were prioritized whether it was the
extra eight billion pounds into Health
and Social care or the additional
funding into education that's exactly
where for you and your family when you
need them they're not right now from
many many people because of this
government's refusal to negotiate on pay
uh well look we we have an independent
pay review body recommendation which
we've accepted uh in full it's important
that you have that process and let's not
forget that last year we had the same
process where the recommendation was
three percent when The Wider for NHS
staff when The Wider public sector uh
was was frozen uh that was at the time
three three times higher uh than than in
inflation
um this year we've accepted those
recommendations in full but it's
important to point out because you you
reference nurses and paramedics but
actually what we're talking about is the
entire agenda for change Workforce which
is 1.24 million people who work within
the NHS they're on this the same agenda
for change contract so any change that's
why it costs 700 million pounds for
every one percent the the ask of the RCN
of some 19.2 equates to 10 billion
pounds now I I will I will however note
that regular points over the past 12
years this conservative government has
ignored or added to the recommendations
of a variety of independent peer-review
bodies I do however I'm sorry I know
you're pushed for time and I want to let
you get away but I just need to ask you
and scan news has been running an
investigation this morning about the
hunter cone group um serious allegations
of failures in care we were first
reported on this in October now again
another 30 patients have come forward
with with legitimate complaints it would
appear what is your department going to
be doing about that well I've seen your
report it's uh totally unacceptable and
if if I were a patient or a family
member of a patient I would rightly want
answers to that too I know having spoken
with my colleague um Minister Maria
Caulfield who has responsibility in this
area she takes it incredibly seriously
and I know both NHS England and the CQC
will want to look at this very closely
indeed
Minister it's great to have you on this
program this morning thanks for joining
us pleasure thank you
let's have a quick look at the weather
the Met Office forecasting that next
year can you believe that going to be
hotter than 2022 one of the warmest on
record and after all the snow and ice it
is practically barbecue weather outside
right now actually I have in Scotland
barbecued in colder temperatures than
this let's get the view of Skies
meteorologist Joe Robinson joining us
from a very dark and Moody looking
Oxford shirt this morning uh Joe just
just bring us up to date what is the
weather going to be looking at as we get
into get into Christmas and tell us just
a little bit about that exceptionally
hot that next year that we're going to
have to look forward to
well yes the Met Office have released
that information that they're
forecasting a central estimate of 1.2
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
period
um average so the last 10 consecutive
years we've seen uh or that including
that year would be make it 10
consecutive years that we've seen
temperatures one degree over the ones
agree
um above pre-industrial time so yes
we've got that information and you know
we've had La Nina that's meant to help
cool things slightly so that is likely
to weigh in as we go into 2023 so that's
why we've got that figure slightly
higher than what we're expecting for
2022 but for now looking at the weather
as we go towards the Christmas period we
are looking at signs of Arctic air
moving back in so there is some
uncertainty of how far south that will
sink so yes need to keep an eye on the
forecast over the next few days
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
so we're looking at some rain across
Eastern England this morning that will
clear and relieve most places Fine Dry
plenty of sunshine today but there will
be some showers across the Northwest and
strong winds there too so blustery
showers there could bring some
thunderstorms as well but mainly dry as
well after that rain clears the Eastern
parts and we're looking at highs today
generally around 10 or 11 degrees
Celsius in the South so in that sunshine
and lighter winds in the South it
shouldn't feel too bad then as we go
through tonight we will see further rain
moving in that will then clear tomorrow
morning and then we'll see showers
continuing in the Northwest again on two
on Wednesday sorry and then yes all
change on Thursday with Arctic air
potentially moving into the North you
know a health Minister has told the
program the government is not willing to
negotiate nurses pay for this year will
Quinn said his and the health secretary
Steve Barclays doors were open for
discussions over working conditions but
that pay is not up for discussion at
this stage the largest issue is is
around Handover delays and that that is
largely about bed occupancy levels
within hospitals flow within hospitals
and discharge into adult social care
they are all issues that we are tackling
but we're also building up resilience
within the ambulance trust to an extra
150 million pounds an extra 20 million
pounds invested in the fleet and as I
say we are investing in more paramedics
too and my door and the door of the
secretary of state is open when it comes
to discussing those issues around
patient safety and working conditions
for staff what we are not willing to
negotiate is reopening the the pay for
this year which is part of the
independent pay review body
recommendations which the government
accepted in full
now let's get the view of our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen I mean you
are listening to the interview with the
minister what did you make
Neil T things jumped out at me the first
is the fact he said the government's
message to the unions in their meeting
this lunchtime would be that category
one and two calls need to be answered by
ambulance workers even during the strike
tomorrow so Category 2 uh being not an
immediate threat to life but something
that could be you know a heart attack or
a stroke or sepsis something that
requires urgent attention he said that's
about 50 of all calls so that's what
they want the ambulance workers to be
answering 50 of all calls it doesn't
sound as if every ambulance trust has
agreed to that so that is a real concern
for ministers trying to get that nailed
down and they are really Keen to get
that done this afternoon whether they
will be able to negotiate that with the
unions remains to be seen the second
thing was with all this discussion about
whether there had been suggestions in
government of whether to give the nurses
a one-off
um pay one-off payment to perhaps
resolve this strike he suggested that
the government was going to hold firm on
this year's pay but the potentially next
year's pay might be where they find some
compromise the government has already
called for evidence because they get all
this evidence in for the the pay review
bodies to decide what the next year's
pay rise will be from April perhaps that
is where a resolution will be found but
it sounds as if the government are very
much standing firm on this year's pay
and that will mean a lot of disruption
not just over Christmas but into the new
year as well
thanks Simona
the conservative MP Bob Stewart has
admitted he made a mistake after being
caught on camera telling a human rights
activist to go back to Bahrain he was
being confronted about a trip paid for
by the Bahraini government ahead of
elections in the country last year
[Music]
I didn't now you shut up you stupid man
did you accept any money
the campaigner Syed awari has since
complained to the conservative party Mr
Stewart told Sky News he had been
guarded into a response and insisted
that he was not a racist he'd also
stressed that he'd never taken a penny
from authorities in Bahrain
some of the other stories making the
news this morning British Airways has
apologized after flights between the
United States and the UK experienced
severe disruption the airline said the
delays were due to a technical issue
some passengers described waiting on
planes on the runway for hours before
being moved back to the airport
the government is to sue a firm linked
to conservative pure Badness moon in a
row over the supply of personal
protective equipment during the pandemic
ministers say that medical gowns
supplied by PPE medpro did not comply
with the specification in the contract
in a statement the company said the
claim would be rigorously defended
the bank of England has unveiled the
design of the King Charles II banknotes
The King's image will appear on the 5 10
20 and 50 pound notes with no other
changes to existing design the new notes
have expected to enter circulation by
mid-2024.
Christmas in Ukraine is going to look
very different this year as the country
marks its first festive season under the
shadow of Russia's Invasion uh back in
March I spoke to senior kuzniak who
movingly told us about how she fled Kiev
with her two daughters and her husband
she shared this video of the moment her
husband returned to Ukraine to fight
foreign
good to see you this morning and Merry
Christmas I hope you're well oh okay I
know thank you so much yes we're we're
doing fine thank you and merry Christmas
as well I'm glad to see that that the
tree is up but but of course I suspect I
suspect that that Christmas in Kiev
right now is going to be slightly
different to the Christmas than I'll
have when I get back home to to Scotland
yeah it's quite different uh we have a
lot of blackouts we don't have this like
Illumination in the streets and usually
we have the lights down but still the
people are celebrating they're degrading
their trees they're trying to share what
they have and they
the mood is really cheerful
um although it's different this
cheerfully is different yeah it will
explain explain that to me because
obviously you're beaming away as I I you
know it is Christmas time and I'm sure
that the girls are getting very very
excited Santa still makes his way you
know no matter the conditions of course
um but but you know there have been any
number of those drone and Rocket attacks
particularly coming very very close to
to where you are right now there are the
power cuts that I imagine will be an
issue for you and many many others there
as well given all of that how do you
keep a smile on your face
[Music]
um
probably because I feel that I'm in the
right place right now I'm just there
where I supposed to be in my city in my
country in my homeland with my citizens
my fellow citizens and um you know it's
pretty amazing because we really have
this
tragic and scaring and dangerous
situation but still everyone is so
standing so good because
um like we know we are unbreakable you
know we have this feeling of gathering
this feeling of um
being together on one side on the right
side and people are so
they're ready to help each other you can
you can just go into any shop and uh say
hi can I charge my phone and everyone
everyone's here yes sure you can we have
these generators on the streets who are
G all the time because shops and like
um restaurants and some cafes they need
to have electricity and they they use
these generators and somehow we get used
to it yes like yesterday we didn't have
power
during the house the whole day we would
cut it off this morning as well I'm just
I'm on the my on my mobile connection I
don't have electricity in my flat right
in my apartment life right now all right
but still
um we feel good you know we feel like
we're doing something right and maybe
that's what help us helps us
how are the girls doing how are the
girls cops and since since we last spoke
because obviously you have made the
decision to go back to key but when we
when we first talked you know you had
you had just you know you're waving
goodbye to your husband as he headed off
to join the military effort I mean how
have they been over the past few months
well we made a decision to come back to
Kiev
IA this cool year
here also had to go to some school
somewhere and we had to decide where and
we came back here because yeah we felt
so miserable when we were somewhere else
we wanted to come home and there's a lot
of people who stay in cave like most of
them stay here because it feels much
safer than like those cities which are
on the
East or on the
South no not South
which are which are close to the front
line but also we have missile attacks
and run attacks here still
somehow we adapt you know somehow we get
used to it uh it feels much scarier when
you look to it when you look at it from
somewhere else but when you're inside
you have so much energy to get through
it so much energy to stand uh with your
family with your neighbors with your
citizens
it feels it gives a lot of this
superpower you know inside super power
Cena tell us then just just a little bit
about about how your husband has been
getting and obviously we saw that uh
very moving bit of video when he was
saying goodbye to you and and the girls
and his you know has been been serving
that for for quite some time how's he
doing
um he's doing fine right now he's near
the bathroom it's a really hot spot uh
on the front line
now we've seen each other maybe in
October we had two days to meet each
other with the girls and me
and right now we have we're out of
connection with him because he can't
like he has no ability to call us for a
few days already but we were hoping he's
fine we believe that
um so we are proud of him we're totally
proud of him we're totally supporting
him we're making some uh we're buying
some gadgets for him for the
drugs which are flying so
we're doing good pretty good I think
given given the circumstances I'd say
you're doing brilliantly uh Xenia um but
but you must you must whilst you are
incredibly proud of him and I'm sure the
girls are as well you must be in a
constant state of you know nervousness
about what what is happening in various
parts of your country and where he is
right now
yes that's true because like I've got
all of all of this scripts of what could
happen to him and what could happen to
us if something happens to him uh and
I'm like rolling it in my head every day
um
but it's it's his decision and it's our
decision as well this is what we
supposed to do what all of us supposed
to do he and us and all of our country
like we we didn't want to we didn't want
this to have this choice and to have
this uh way
but it what happens to us and you have
to take this you have no other way
what then because of course Christmas
the New Year it's a time for for
regeneration it's a time for planning
ahead it's time for making resolutions
and and a little bit of Hope for the
future I wonder given what has been
happening to your country for for most
of this year whether you have much hope
for for 2023
oh God I I I'm just telling you not to
think about it actually because when
we're looking uh like what happened we
had this everyone had the covet because
of your coronavirus in the lockdown then
we had war and we're having it right now
so we're just hoping it's not gonna get
worse that would be okay for us really
um we want to win we want to have
Victory that's our main goal and Main
wish we all make under the Christmas
tree well that is the main thing isn't
it we had a handful of days away from
Christmas Day Santa is getting the
sleigh loaded up already just tell me
what what is your Christmas day like uh
in Keith
well
um usually we I when I wake up I'm just
trying to turn on the light to just to
understand is there any electricity or
no uh mostly I don't but uh I mean it's
okay we got used to it we have power
Banks we have candles uh and I was born
in in Kiev which in early 90s it was
pretty much the same we had a lot of uh
Power Downs
uh my girls go to school which is next
next door to us
um they somehow study with their
teachers if there's a air alert teachers
take them to the shelter to the subway
uh I don't go to the subway usually
because I stay here in my Corridor which
is um we you know we have these two
walls rule rule because
um if you stay in some area where
there's no windows and which is behind
two walls uh it's safer than if you stay
like like I'm here right now near next
to the video so if there's any missile
attacks we go to the corridor behind two
walls
um if we see that there's a lot of like
we we checked news newsline to
understand if they're a big missile
attack or drone attack if it's big and
we can go to Subway also also or to stay
out we just can decide to stay home in
the corridor we have like a small
shelter here there oh
something like that then we if if uh if
I see that the electricity is on I'm
trying to get all my uh house working
done really quickly like
to wash dishes to do everything
um
I don't know it feels like um
like we're in some kind of weird reality
I'm also trying to remember it really
good I'm just trying to write down some
of my day life uh thoughts just remember
it because it's a really strange
strange part of my life really strange
year I can imagine I can imagine
um well senior I I really hope that you
and the girls have a wonderful Christmas
time and that your husband gets back to
you all soon uh so the family can
celebrate together uh but from all of us
here look wishing you your family a hand
all of your friends and and relations
all the very best for 2023 uh Cena you
take care
thank you so much have a merry Christmas
as well
time for the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
or after an exceptionally mild start to
the week temperatures falling closer to
the average for the time of year
overnight rain will lie over East Anglia
and the southeast this morning elsewhere
mostly dry and bright with temperatures
in the mid-single figures it will be
blustery in the north and west with
showers that may turn heavy at times
disguise will brighten in the Southeast
this afternoon to leave a largely dry
day with showers running into Scotland
Northern Ireland and Northern England
whether it's this morning to review the
papers the entrepreneur Kate Hardcastle
and the editor-in-chief of national
world cities Nancy Fielder I'd love to
see you both again and and Nancy what
are you from it's the front of the at
first and it's the front of the times
and this is the ambulance strike due
tomorrow and concerns that that some
very very sick people might not be able
to get an ambulance
yes this is what happens when people who
don't want to in care roles are forced
for strike because the government won't
listen to them because we've got an NHS
that for several reasons but one of the
big one being that people don't want to
work there they leave and there aren't
enough people being recruited back
because it's a really difficult place to
work this is what happens but let's also
reflect back quickly on headlines we've
had for several years in the newspapers
people have been denied full NHS
services and full ambulance services
because the service is in crisis so the
strikes are inevitably going to make it
worse but they don't have to have these
strikes the government has chosen to go
head-to-head
World lies around the economics of
whether we can afford pay risers and I
think the country is on the side of the
NHS workers and it's awful that people
will possibly die because the government
won't negotiate on this and won't take
Serious action yeah and certainly when I
put that very question to to the
minister of the health Minister this
morning he would not be drawn into
making That explicit statement I want to
go across uh the Atlantic
um Kate you've got the story inside the
guardian today and this uh U.S
congressional committee actually
recommending some pretty significant
criminal charges against Donald Trump
it's definitely a milestone in that
we've got a point where this committee
that has been going for 18 months
they've had over a thousand interviews
has reached the recommendation that
Trump should face charges but I think if
we go back two years to that very
Infamous tweet where I think it was
exactly maybe two years for the day
Donald Trump went out and said it will
be wild because this very frustrated
president uh this desperate president
was wanting to change the outcome of
that election suggesting that they've
been fraud and it's been quite the
journey so far and I think what we have
to understand from all of the detailed
report that come through is there still
a long way to go before we know if this
actually manifests itself into those
charges what will happen then and in the
meantime we still have Mr Trump who has
announced that he will run for 2024 uh
with the very possibility of still doing
so of course everything is down to the
American public and how they react to
What Might unfold from there
um Nancy we're going to skip ahead a
couple of stories because I've got it
written down on my list as mail page
three hobnobs you get 30 seconds take it
away
this is a vital piece of research from
the British Medical
District that survived the longest if
you dunk it and I was suggesting
Christmas week every single viewer goes
out and tries this because I think we
all need a hobnob to cheer us up after a
grim round of news do you know well you
want you are you are shaking your head
there you're not a hob-knob fan are you
I absolutely love dunking a Biscuit in
my Brew believe me but hobnobs to leave
residue in the bottom nail it's not nice
this is all getting a little bit too
redolent of a Peter K routine for my
liking so do you know what we're both
gonna we're gonna leave it there